desde la casa blanca por televisión
donald trump fue testigo del asalto a la
democracia estadounidense
el comité del congreso encargado de
investigar los sucesos del 6 de enero de
2021 reveló detalles sobre las acciones
o la falta de ellas del ex presidente
como
hemos confirmado en numerosas
entrevistas con altos líderes policiales
y militares con el vicepresidente pence
su personal y funcionarios del gobierno
que ninguno de ellos escuchó al
presidente de trump ese día no llamó
para dar órdenes no llamó para ofrecer
asistencia
la investigación determinó que los
asesores del ex presidente le
aconsejaron a trump que ordenara a la
multitud que abandonar el capitolio unas
recomendaciones que omitió
no hay duda de que el comando una turba
una turba quiere sabía que estaba
fuertemente armada violenta y enfurecida
para que marchará hacia el capitolio en
un intento de evitar la transferencia
pacífica del poder de fax estos hechos
son indiscutibles por lo que debe haber
rendición de cuentas ante la ley y ante
el pueblo
impulsado por el partido demócrata y con
la participación de únicamente dos
congresistas republicanos el comité
presentó algunas de las nuevas pruebas
entre ellas un audio del general marc
mil y en el que se escucha sorprendido
con la reacción del mandatario
las revelaciones llegan en la última
sesión televisada de dicho comité antes
del receso de verano en otoño reanudará
sus sesiones en las que tendrá que
entregar el informe final tras
considerar informaciones y nuevos
testigos que se han presentado en las
últimas semanas